CORINNA CORTES: I'm sorry
if I'm not too dressed up,
but I was told that I could
just show up in my regular work
clothing, so this is
actually how I often
end up coming to work.
So, yes, I've been here
for more than 10 years,
and that means that
seniority-wise I'm
in the 99.8 percentile
or something like that.
When I started it was
actually a very small office
in Times Square.
So my plan the next-- I
thought I had 45 minutes.
I didn't leave any time
for questions, by the way.
I wasn't aware that you
had anything to say, right?
But my idea was to
tell a little bit
about how I ended
up in the tech world
and give some examples of
work that are happening,
is happening in my team.
But maybe I should just ask
you a few questions first.
How many of you-- show of
hands-- actually associated
with the tech world?
Students or professionals
or anything?
Oh.
That is almost everybody.
How many are actually
students though?
A good amount.
So two more questions.
When you, a couple
of years ago, started
telling friends and
family that you wanted
to pursue a degree in science,
computer science, whatever,
did you meet any objections?
Show of hands.
You did?
Who told you anything?
AUDIENCE: Well, because it's
not like a career like medicine
or law that's known
to be successful.
So it's kind of a new thing
that my family wasn't aware of.
CORINNA CORTES: So they were
sort of reluctant about that?
Yeah.
OK, well, but fortunately
it wasn't too many
here that had any objections.
But inside yourself, how
did you feel about it?
Did you think, I really don't
want really to be a nerd
and be associated with all that?
I don't want to
be the Amy Farrah
Fowler in "Big Bang Theory."
I mean, I wanted more
to be like Penny, right?
Except for I wanted a degree.
Yeah, OK.
That's better.
Let's be honest, right?
My goodness, you
knew what you wanted.
OK.
Well, so I still think
that we have a little ways
to go with this
perception of what
is a woman in computer science.
But we have come a
long way from that we
don't get too much objections
to when we come and say
we want to have a
degree in science.
And I just want to
point out that it
wasn't like that
about 60 years ago.
Here we have a very proud woman.
She looks very happy, and
she has all good reasons
to be happy.
She has a Ph.D. In agriculture.
And at this point in her
life, she's in her mid-50s
just like me.
She has developed
a new wheat brand.
I don't know if
you call it brand,
but that is more robust
towards diseases.
So it's less pesticides
in the ground.
It's less fertilizers.
And at this point of
time it was actually
covering like 20% of the wheat
fields in northern Germany
and Scandinavia.
So very impressive career.
What the picture doesn't
show is that she only
got her Ph.D. five years before.
OK.
So when she was contemplating
going to university,
she knew exactly what
she wanted to become.
But her parents said,
no, no, no, no, no.
A good girl like you don't go
into any science or technology
like that.
And it wasn't as
much that she would
have to move to the big
city, because there wasn't
a technical university
where she lived.
Because they did send
her to the big city
to teach her housekeeping and
cooking and all these things.
And it wasn't that her
family wasn't well-educated.
Her father was a civil
engineer, and her older brother
had been sent to the technical
university in the big city just
three years before.
It was simply that a nice
girl shouldn't get a degree
in any kind of
science or technology.
So what did she do?
Well, she became a
kindergarten teacher,
and I benefited a lot from that.
That's my mother.
Yeah.
So as time passed, it happened
that we moved to the big city,
and when my older sister started
contemplating going to school,
going to the university,
my mother sort of
got back to this.
And one day she
came home and said,
I'm going to brush up on
my math, and my physics,
and my chemistry, and I'm
going to go to school.
So when she was 44, something
like that, she enrolled,
and she got her Ph.D. and
obviously was very successful.
So that has always been a
good inspiration for me.
And you would think
then with a background
like that, my own
career-- simple, right?
I was also good in
math and physics
in school, so why not just go
to the university and study it?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We found something much more
effective than these parents
telling us what to do
and what not to do,
and that's the peer pressure
that I believe is around.
We don't want to go
into these degrees.
So here you have me
when I was 17 or 18.
Do I look as somebody who wants
to go in and study physics?
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
I wanted to do something where
the boys wouldn't be running
away if I met them in a bar,
and I said I'm studying physics,
right?
So I went for something
innocent-- theology.
Now don't-- it's not as
bad as you think actually,
because in Denmark we
have a state religion.
So studying theology
is not that uncommon.
But I did realize
after some months
that I was probably heading
to become a priest then.
Maybe that was not the
career call for me though.
In retrospect, I must
say, that being a manager
or being a priest,
I don't really
know if there's that
much of a difference.
Right?
It's all about
guiding lost souls.
So I changed.
OK.
I went to literature.
Still very innocent.
I can walk up to any boy and
say, I'm studying literature.
Right?
And he'd say, oh, very nice.
I wasn't happy there either.
Fortunately, I was
short on money.
All students are.
So in January just like here,
in Denmark, the universities
they are closed, and I went
to the student job center
to get a job.
Now we're talking
the early 80s, so I
thought it was
really, really cool
to get a job at a conveyor belt.
Right?
I had to feel what the
working class was all about.
Right?
So I got this job, and
I had to adjust engines
for vacuum cleaners
for eight hours a day.
The other students that
have picked the same job,
they were actually
engineering students.
And I discovered they
were really, really nice.
I could actually go out and have
a beer with them afterwards,
and they arranged ski trips.
If you go to their parties,
also, you're the only girl,
and there are all
these nice girls.
That's a benefit.
So finally after
a lot of detours,
I ended up studying physics and
later math, computer science,
and that's how I ended
up in this field.
But it was a detour
of about two,
three years before
I dared actually
go in and pursue the degree
that I really wanted to get.
So I made it through
graduate life, and just
my five pieces of advice.
There's probably way too many.
For the ones that
are still students,
get the most out of
your graduate time.
And I mean on the
technical side, right?
Nowadays, particularly, they
try to stuff all kinds of fluff
into the computer science degree
to make it more attractive.
At least if you want
to get a job at Google,
not that you necessarily--
but in general,
if you want to
get a job, I think
it's important that you learn
as many core skills as possible
while you are in school.
Don't specialize too much
so you cannot easily adapt
to something else.
Right?
Take all your programming,
the algorithms,
the kind of hard
courses, data structures.
It will pay off.
No matter where you want
to go in the future.
Right?
You will have the foundation
to really get a good job.
Publish while you're
in graduate school.
I learned that
too late, I think.
But when you want
to apply for a job,
it's really good to have
a couple of publications
on your resume.
And it also makes writing
the thesis much, much easier.
You could write it around
a few publications.
Don't drag it out.
Ask your advisor to sit down
with you and make a plan,
because writing that thesis,
it's not that big a deal.
Right?
We all think that this
is going, oh, no, no, no.
We're never going
to get through it.
But it really isn't,
especially if you
have a couple of publications,
so you kind of staged it.
Be competitive.
Get all the As that
you can, but try
to be good friends also
with-- leverage of each other.
Make good use of the other
students, especially the girls,
I found, It's kind of
strange, because now
in my professional
life, I get so much
out of interacting
with the other women,
but I found in graduate
school, we were just competing,
and we were kind of being
nasty against each other.
It's really a pity
to somehow try
to be good friends, especially
with your female classmates.
Keep a hobby.
Don't make your hobby
into your profession.
That was one advice
I was once given.
I have a hobby.
I run.
And that's the
way I keep saying.
Right?
I've been out doing
22 miles this morning.
That's why I look like this.
I wouldn't miss it.
I meet with my other
girlfriends at 7 o'clock
up in Central Park,
and we run around.
I do it every
Saturday, also today.
The family thing, right?
It's hard.
There's never a good time.
So my mother told me, my good
old mother that's otherwise
a fine woman, she said, you
first have to get a degree.
You have to get a
job, and then you
get a man and your children.
I don't know.
There's never a good time.
I would say don't put it
off too much, because it's
kind of hard to have children.
It's a lot of work, right?
And the older we get, the
more tired we actually get.
So I would rather have started
a little earlier, I think.
And then, you know, if you don't
like the education you're in,
change.
Don't stick with it.
You're going to have
to live with this
the rest of your life.
Just get out, and change.
Don't be shy about it.
Say it's not fit for me.
I definitely did that a
couple of times, and my mother
had to do it.
Afterwards, find a job
that's right for you.
I see a lot of
students coming out,
and they think
maybe that academia,
that's the golden standard.
Right?
That's where we
should be heading.
We shouldn't go into industry.
But in reality, they don't
like to stand in front of--
and they don't like to teach.
They don't like to be up in
the spotlight all the time.
And the sweat is sort
of howling from them.
But academia, that's
where I should be.
Find what's good for you.
If you work best
in small groups,
then there are plenty of
other options for you.
Google is one great place.
They got to have to stop
pitching this place.
I really think it's a nice
place, because we work together
in small groups.
And really what counts is
the technical abilities
of what you're doing.
You don't have to
be the one who brags
about how wonderful
your worker is.
It's simply, if it works,
then you have a say.
So there are many ways you can
have your professional life.
Don't do something that
you're not happy in.
Always keep in mind, what is
it I want to leave behind?
Because there's a tendency
that we fall into these local
minimas.
Right?
Where we just go along.
But sometimes you should
just stop and say,
what is it I would like
to leave behind when I go?
Is it a couple of good papers?
Is it-- I mean, on
a technical side.
Let's take the other things at
a different-- think about it,
and work towards.
Don't forget it.
Because otherwise we
tend to just flatten out.
And again, if you're not
happy in your job, change job.
It's not that bad.
You go into Humanities
and you say, I'm changing.
And he won't kill you.
We tend to get stuck, and
that's kind of a pity.
So enough of my
pointed fingers here.
I'd like to just spend a
little bit of time telling you
about some of the great things
that the people on my team
are doing.
I don't do all the work.
So I'm heading the research
group here in New York.
And we have-- it's like a little
computer science department
except we don't
have the products,
and we don't have a whole lot
of the theoretical complexity
hierarchies and
things like that.
I definitely have a
lot of computer vision,
and I'd like to start out by
showing you some of the work
that we've done in
computer vision.
And let's start out
with a visualiz-- nah,
let's first go back
and do something.
OK?
We're going to take the
picture here of my mother.
And we're going to
save it on the desktop.
Good.
All right.
And now we're going to
go to this application.
It's called Visually
Similar Images,
and you probably
all Image Search.
This is a good old
Google Image Search
as we have come to live
and love it for many years.
But you may have noticed up here
that there's a little camera.
Right?
So you can actually
do search by image.
OK?
So upload an image.
Now choose the file,
and I would believe now
that image-- here is it.
OK.
All right.
So this one is definitely
not in the index.
Right?
Because we just created it.
So we're going to open.
We're uploading the
file, and look at that.
Right.
In real time, we get actually
very good images, I would say.
Very similar images,
and look at here.
Right?
So this is not cheating.
Wheat, if I say that
I also want that,
I mean you couldn't ask
to get it much better.
Right?
Look here.
Another person standing
in a wheat field.
Right?
Many people standing
in a wheat field.
Look at this one.
She's even better-looking,
almost, than my mother.
All right.
And just so that you think
that I'm not cheating,
let's see here.
No, that's moment.
That's not really
where we want to be.
That's how I enter it,
so let's just go too.
Google-- I just want
to show that we're not
cheating, because if I had
gone here, and I said, "wheat,"
I would get something
completely different.
So it actually made use
of the image and the text
that I gave with the image,
and it did a special search
that was different
from just going
to Image Search with
the word "wheat."
I think I just lost
my presentation.
That's OK.
I can find it again.
I'm sure I can find it again.
I did a mistake.
I shouldn't have done
it like that, but so.
All right.
So how do we do it?
Just through-- we should
go back also here.
I have to do a little
adjustment like this.
Let's spend three minutes
building an image browser
together.
Now the first thing
that we would need
is, of course, a similarity
matrix between two images.
Right?
We'll represent the images
by say, some vectors, right?
And this is not just going to be
a vector of the pixel elements
in the image, because
that's not very robust.
If I rescale the
image, then the vectors
have a different length.
Computer science, the
computer vision people,
they're very good at coming up
with good image descriptors.
They're called sift features,
and all these things.
So let's imagine that we
have two images that we want
to have the similarity between,
and these computer vision
people, they've given
us a number of features.
We are extracting
them from the images,
and for simplicity, let's just
say that the similarity, that's
the inner product
between these two images.
The vectors representing
these two images.
We're projecting one
vector down on the other.
And the more they're aligned,
the more the similarity is.
Let's now say that we want
to build image collection
for the query, New York.
What would we do?
Well, we would probably say, OK.
We'll go to the information
retrieval people,
and they'll tell us, if you
want images for New York,
why don't you scrape
all the pages that
contain the word "New York"
and have images on it.
Probably those images
on those pages,
since the page
mentioned New York,
the images are
relevant for New York.
Right?
So we'll take maybe, say
10,000 images that we've
found on pages that mention
New York, and we can do,
we can extract the features.
We'll do the inner product.
We'll find all
these similarities
between the thousands
and thousands of images,
and then we can build
our clustering tree.
We'll build them bottom up.
We'll say the ones that
are the most similar,
we'll cluster together, and
then we'll build it forward up,
and we'll get this
cluster tree, and then
if somebody wants to do
a search for New York,
well, what we can do is we
can cut the clustering tree
at some kind of level.
Right?
So we have maybe,
I hate when I don't
have the screen in front of me.
So say that we cut
it about here, right?
And we present back to
the user these clusters
of images representing
different aspects of New York.
And that was
exactly what we did.
Right?
The first similar
images is this one,
and you're going
to see something
that used to be out
there, but now it
only exists inside
the Google firewall.
Here we have what was
called Image Swirl,
and we have put in
the query New York,
and then you could go
down here, and you'll
get these clusters
of images, and you
could continue down
and play with it.
So here, give me a query.
Which image cluster
would you like to see?
AUDIENCE: Bridges.
CORINNA CORTES: Bridges.
OK.
Bridges.
All right.
I'm sure that this
woman, actually her name
is probably something
with Bridges, right?
I would think so.
Otherwise, it makes sense.
But this is a silly thing.
Right?
Computer are pretty
stupid, right?
Because they take the
word very literally.
I'm sure that her
name is Bridges.
Do we know who she is?
AUDIENCE: No.
CORINNA CORTES: I'm
pretty sure there's
a very logical
explanation for this.
Google is not very smart.
But one thing you
see here, if we
type in "international
women's--" OK.
Sorry this query is not
included in your demo.
So the problem here is that
the first similar images
we constructed, it
was all pre-computed.
Why did it have to
be pre-computed?
Well, think of the process
that I outlined for you
that we were actually doing
in order to create this.
We would execute a query,
go out and get 10,000 pages
with images, pages that
contain this query word.
We'll extract the images,
we'll form the feature vectors.
So say we now have 10,000
images over feature vectors,
we'll have to compute all
the [INAUDIBLE] similarities.
That's 10,000 by 10,000.
I think it gets something like
100 million inner products
we have to form.
Built the clustering, cut
it, and present it back
in web time.
And web time is how much?
Less than a second.
Right?
200 milliseconds.
Google has a lot of
resources, but we
don't have that many resources.
So we had to do something,
and that was to pre-compute.
So Image Swirl was only working
for the top 20,000 queries.
But we want to do something
that is broader than that.
So we had to find
something smarter.
And now I again done
something stupid,
so I have to go
back and find my--
I've got to stop doing
this stupid thing where--
because I actually know
how to avoid doing it.
We had to do something
smarter, and what we do instead
is that we cheat.
No.
It's not called
cheating in this world.
It's called, we approximate.
All right.
So what do we do?
We stayed out.
We built the clustering to kind
of top down instead of bottom
up, right?
We first take all the
images that we can find out
on the web, and we extract
these feature vectors for them.
Make them very short.
We don't want to spend too much
time on taking inner products.
And then we randomly
take some direction
in this space of
feature vectors.
Right?
And we project down
on that direction.
Do you fall on this side of it,
or do you fall on that side?
So the images that fall on this
side, they go down that path,
and the images on the other
side go down that path.
And we continue growing
the tree top down
until we have a couple
of thousand nodes down
at the bottom.
And with each image, we
save the ID off the node
that it ended up in.
Actually each image, we cheat
a little bit also there.
Right?
Because if you're very close
to the boundary at some point
in time, we don't want you
just to go down on that side,
and we would never
find you there.
So we spill a little
bit, so every image
ends up being in
about five nodes.
So what do we do at query time?
Well, we take the
query image, the one
that I uploaded of my mother,
and we extract the feature
vector for that query image, and
then we send it down the tree.
Now it's down in some node.
We extract all the other images
that are down in that node.
We can afford to do the
similarity with at least some
of them down there.
And we present that back to you.
If we additionally have keywords
like the word "wheat," then
we only consider
the images that were
found on a page that also
mention the word "wheat."
So that's how we are doing
the image search nowadays.
Now because you
are here at Google
today, I can show you how these
clusters actually look like.
And now I'm going to do it
the smart way, because now I
know I'm better.
Right?
This is cluster numbers
700, a random cluster
in this tree we built of all the
images that we find on the web.
And you can see, it's
kind of similar in a way.
It's a lot of faces, right?
And what we can
actually do here is
we can say if we additionally
had the word "International
Women's Day," what would we get?
Look at that.
Right?
There actually,
well, of course we
get the First Lady,
Michelle Obama.
Then we get a very sad,
very inspirational image
as the second one.
A women all hidden.
Right?
With the little birds
in a cage on top.
We could've taken
another 900 just
so you get a feeling
for how different
the images actually are
in the various nodes.
1,400.
Let's do 1200 instead.
That it doesn't like either.
1100.
OK.
I broke something.
Here we are.
So they have very
different color tones,
and depending on
what node you are in.
But this is how visual similar
images, they're working.
So now you learned a
little bit about what's
going on inside one
of these applications
that you see online.
Let me show you another
application also
if I can find my presentation,
which I can never do so.
I don't know what I did now.
Where is my tap?
Oh, the third-- it's
good that I have you.
You are more with it than--
So in my groups
inside we-- OK, these
are just in case I couldn't
get anything to work.
Since we now successfully
had managed to give you back
similar images,
we thought that we
can master any kind
of similarities.
So we went on to the
next kind of similarities
that we thought was interesting,
and that was time series.
This is actually a very
interesting project
that some of you
may have heard of.
How many have heard
about Flu Trends?
Well, I have.
OK.
So Flu Trends is a project
we formed here at Google.
It is trying to measure
the current level of flu
in any country.
The Centers for
Disease Control only
reports at the end of
the month the number
of people that went
to doctors and were
diagnosed with having the flu.
So if we want to meter what
is the flu level in the US
we have to wait until
the end of the month.
That is a long
time to wait if we
want to produce
vaccines, for instance.
So how can we get a current
estimate of the flu level
in the US?
Well, some smart people at
Google-- they are awfully smart
of them-- they thought,
well, if people have the flu,
somebody in their
family has the flu,
maybe they search online
for runny nose, temperature,
symptoms of flu, things
that are sort of correlated
with having the flu.
We're not talking causality.
This is very important.
We're just talking, what is
correlated with things here?
So the project is called Google
Correlate, and that is actually
available out in
the public world.
Their first application
was this Flu Trend,
so they had them--
let me show you.
So this is the time series
in blue from the CDC.
We have the number of reported
incidents of flu as the doctors
they have come up with him
from going back to 2005.
And we have a query
term "influenza type A."
How many instances we've had
of that query, or what time,
and you can see they are
pretty well correlated.
So if I, in 2011, were to
predict at some point of time,
what is the flu level despite
that I haven't observed
the level from CDC, this would
be a good estimator of it.
The true model is built
on, I think, 40 keywords
or something like that.
We do not make
publicly available
what these keywords
they are, in order not
to get the model spammed.
Because then people could sit
there and artificially hike up
the current level of flu.
But we have this site called
Flu Trends where you can go in,
and you can see the
current level of flu.
This is from the other
day, and fortunately you
can see this year it
hasn't been as bad as it's
been some of the past years.
And we are on the
way down, though I
must admit that I've been
sick the last couple of days.
We also try to do it
for some other diseases.
This is for the United States.
We have it for a number
of other countries,
and you can in the United
States actually drill down
to the city level, and get what
is the current level of flu
as we estimated based on query
terms that are coordinated
with these CDC numbers,
or historically
have been correlated
with the CDC numbers.
What do we believe
that the current flu
level is in the various cities?
Now what we would like
to make available for you
so you can make your
own flu models, right?
Or you can have your
own series of something
that you'd like to find
something correlated with
and write a new article.
And we actually had this as
a paper in nature, right?
We want you to discover
correlations and find things
in the world that can be
to benefit of everyone.
So we have worked on getting Flu
Trends or Correlate out there
as publicly available data.
So what we found
out was, however,
that this simple version
we've done for the images,
it didn't work one
bit for time series.
Now with time series,
there's this thing.
They go along, and then
there's kind of a change point.
And then they have a
different behavior,
and then there's a change point.
And then they have a
different behavior.
So we found out
that in order for us
to find good correlations, we
had to do something different.
And we did what we call
asymmetric hashing,
and it has to be a little bit
of equations also here today.
So what we do is we take
all our query time series,
and we split them into chunks.
Well, we cannot detect change
points for each time series,
so we just all- everybody's
going to have to live with
the same change points.
Right?
So we split them into N
or K, so that it's N long,
and then we want to
have N our K chunks.
And now each chunk, we're going
to represent with a cluster
center.
So we decided we can't afford
to have a whole lot of cluster
centers, so we're just going to
take all these little chunks,
and then we're going
to find 256 centers.
We run a K means algorithm
to find these centers.
And now we are going to
represent all our queries just
with these N or K centers,
for which the first chunk was
most similar to
center number 10.
The next chunk was most
similar to center number 14,
so we just instead
of a time series,
we get a sequence of what
centers it was most similar to.
That we can call kind of a
hash code for the time series,
for all our query streams
that we've had over.
Now when we come in with a new
time series, all we have to do
is we have to divide
it into the chunks.
We can compute each chunk's
distance to the centers,
and now if I want to find the
distance from the new time
series to one of
my query streams,
I just have to do
N or K additions.
Does that mean I'm out of time?
OK.
I did start late, but I-- OK.
We call it asymmetric,
because it's
asymmetric in that we keep
the real data of the new time
series we come in
with, but we only
keep the hash code for
all the query terms.
So let me give you an example
of how it's actually working.
Here we have the site, and
you can go and play with it
yourself.
OK.
March Madness.
Who knows what March Madness is?
I know.
Not a big surprise.
Right?
March Madness has big
peaks in March, right?
But what do we find that
the series-- so here we
are taking as our
new time series
is the one that corresponds
to the query term, "March
Madness." so what is
correlated with March Madness?
When people search
for March Madness,
what do they also search for?
AUDIENCE: Beer.
CORINNA CORTES: Beer.
No, you see what comes up here.
It's a basketball, NCAA
tournament, it's brackets.
I think that's a system
for how you can show more.
And if you're logged on, you can
also upload into your own data.
So if you had the CDC
data or something else,
you can upload
that and find where
it's correlated
with that, so you
can build your own
Flu Trends model.
We can take something else that
you also know-- Super Bowl.
Uh-oh.
If I could just spell,
it would be a plus.
Right?
Super Bowl.
What on earth is
that, you think?
Yeah, it's Japanese.
But ladies and gentleman, there
are a few gentleman here also.
Now look at this.
Come on.
OK.
So we're here.
It's not a big surprise
that it came up.
Right?
The project internally was
actually called Mittens,
and there's an
explanation for that.
Because it's kind
of cute, right?
Mittens, you have,
of course, you're
searching for it in a
window, but look at what's
correlated with it also.
Knit hat, wool socks,
things like that.
Spring.
We're all thinking spring.
It's nice outside today.
And if we say we don't want
anything that has spring in it,
baseball cleats.
Track Spikes.
We want to go out and
use our body weight.
Dress shop.
Wedding.
It used to bring up diet.
Let's see what it
does these days.
No.
We got the diet out.
I think this is the place
you go for your honeymoon.
All right.
These are always
fun to play with.
We can also do more
childcare job posting.
Family law.
It's actually interesting
about the job posting.
There was some article the other
day that one of the reasons
that women, they
don't stay in jobs,
and they don't
complete in academia
as much as-- it's hard
to have both a job
and take care of your children.
All right.
So give me a word
that you'd like
to see the correlations with.
AUDIENCE: Hamburger.
CORINNA CORTES: Hamburger?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
CORINNA CORTES: Oh.
I forgot the R.
That is interesting.
Flink.
Mt.
Pleasant.
I have no idea why
we-- It looks OK.
I'm sorry we have a
problem with the data
here in the
beginning of January.
We're correcting next week, so
if you go in and play with it
next week, you shouldn't see
all these horrendous things.
Virginia?
You want the correlations
for Virginia?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CORINNA CORTES:
Well, I'm happy to.
I don't know.
I mean there's often
a good explanation.
If you go online, you'll find
that there was probably some--
OK.
And you see when I visit
schools, if I go to MIT,
I put in and say
what do people also
think of when I-- The
other day I was in Finland.
Right?
It's hockey.
That's the only thing
they care about.
Finland and hockey.
OK.
I encourage you to
play with this site.
It's a lot of fun, and the
reason we put it out there
is of course that we
hope that somebody
is going to discover some
great correlations and advance
humanity.
Whatever.
OK.
So I should probably try to
wrap up, because otherwise we're
going to be sitting
here all day.
And I'm already six
minutes overtime despite,
but I did start late.
I can talk forever, right.
Other projects that
have come from my team--
Chinese handwriting for Android.
Right?
Can you imagine when
you have to-- there must
be a lot of Asians
here that, and they
use to enter this
hideous keyboard.
Right?
How do you do that?
AUDIENCE: No idea.
CORINNA CORTES: No idea?
No.
It must be impossible.
I cannot.
So what we came up with was
a handwriting application
where you can actually write.
And then you can get-- it's
an extension of something
like that.
Download it and play with it.
So for a lot of the Asian
languages, you can write,
and you can get suggestions
for what it's recognized at.
And it's getting an
enormous amount of traffic.
And speech recognition.
I must say that I'm very proud
that I have the team that's
behind all the algorithms in
the Google Speech Recognizer
that I'm sure that
we all have used.
It still needs a little work.
It's not very good in Danish.
I can say that.
So please if you're
still in graduate school,
try to learn a little bit about
signaling processing for speech
recognition, and the
algorithms behind that,
and join Google, because
we still need you.
We still need you.
All these problems,
as you can see,
they're far from
solved problems.
We're just scratching
the surface,
but we try to put out at least
something that is usable.
And I think the
speech recognition
at least in English,
is getting to the level
where it is meaningful.
I sometimes at least try
to dictate email messages
and then correct
them afterwards.
Somehow my accent
is not good for it.
It's funny, because
the father of my kids,
he's actually one of these
people behind the algorithms.
And he's working in speech
recognition for 25 years.
He's French, and he
also has an accent.
But when he speaks
to this telephone,
he just becomes another person.
And he has this
perfect pronunciation
that doesn't sound
one bit like him.
But it recognizes it perfectly.
So maybe we can-- we'll
get somewhere adapting.
We adapt to the machines, and
the machines also get better,
and eventually we'll be able
to recognize each other.
So these are just
examples of the projects
that I have in my group.
I'm the very proud
mother of this group.
I have built it all.
So this is where I am today.
You've seen a few of them.
You've seen that I run.
Right?
I do run.
That's my hobby.
And that does mean
that I was up at 5
o'clock this morning
to go out for my run.
It's hard to get it
all to fit together.
I like to do my research.
I'm a manager here,
and I have my twins
that are now just
turned teenagers.
You can do it all.
It does require a lot of will,
and the day is not long enough.
I could easily use five
hours extra in every day.
But I encourage you still
to pursue all your dreams,
because you can fit
it in if you want to.
And if you are stuck in
something that you don't really
like, be honest to yourself.
Get out of it.
Change your job.
Change your education.
It's not too late.
You still have a lot
of years ahead of you.
OK?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm supposed to take questions.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I was going to say.
CORINNA CORTES: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Can you come to the mic?
Just because we
want to hear people.
AUDIENCE: I know you
started with academia,
and you have very
impressive credentials.
But what do you think
about getting into teach
without ever going to school?
Which is like what I did.
And I'm supposedly in
the highest percentile
per hour for making
money in the country.
And I think it's a good
opportunity for women,
so that's always my preach.
[? Mooks. ?] You know.
Lynda.com.
Get a job.
Just keep moving up.
CORINNA CORTES: I have
no experience in that.
I'm impressed that
you have made it.
Very good for you,
but maybe you're
the one who should instead
be coming up at some point
and tell these
women here today how
it is possible without going
into a formal degree first.
I kind of did it the
easy way, I could say.
AUDIENCE: I never had
a class in IT ever.
CORINNA CORTES: You didn't?
AUDIENCE: No.
CORINNA CORTES: And
they still accept you?
AUDIENCE: They didn't care.
They don't care.
Not anymore.
30 years.
CORINNA CORTES: Good for you.
You managed somehow.
Usually I tell people
to stay in school
and get their diploma
just because it hedges
your best for later on in life.
AUDIENCE: If you can afford it.
See my point is that a lot
of women can't afford it.
You know?
I couldn't afford
it when I was 17.
CORINNA CORTES:
[? Mooks ?] are out here?
There's also a lot of junk.
Yeah.
But congratulations to you.
You'll come up later
and tell everybody
how to do it without
going to school.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Corinna.
It's privilege to have you here.
It's really nice.
I have question.
So when your engineers are
trying to create a product,
and they're also
trying to create
a product in the
research-oriented stream,
how do they manage being
productive in the sense
like creating the software,
but at the same time
discovering something new?
CORINNA CORTES: That's
a very good question,
and it is a tricky balance.
So all the
researchers at Google,
we are of course at
Google, because we
like the ideas, the
mission of Google,
and we want to contribute
to the Google brand.
If we were not
interested in that,
we would probably
be in academia.
So it's whenever you go out and
make a cup of coffee at Google
and talk to any random
person out there,
you'll find that they're
working on something fascinating
that you would love
to contribute to.
For my researchers, I tell
them that they shouldn't
be consultants to
their projects.
Right?
They should try to find a novel
aspect in a project where they
cannot just say, go
and read this paper,
and it will be a good
algorithm for you to do.
They should try to
go for their projects
where there really is
something new and exciting
for them to do.
And they often end
up actually sitting
for a long time with
the engineering teams
in order to find out what
the engineering team really
wants to do.
Then I ask them
after they'd done
that to come back to
the research group
and write up what was it that
was the novel thing about what
they did?
In what way was the
solution optimal?
It can be computational
complexity,
or it can be whatsoever.
Right?
But they have to have a good
reason for why they did it,
why they recommend
it, the way they did.
So we try to balance
these things.
Trying to in a research team
to go for the novel things
that nobody has found a
good solution to before.
But yeah, it's often something
that you spend some time doing
product development,
and then you come home
and you write up
the paper about it.
We also try to generalize the
algorithms then and write it up
as libraries and give
it back as open source.
For instance, all
the speech algorithms
that are out there as
open source libraries,
so they can be used
by universities
or other industries.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi, Corinna.
First of all, I loved
your quote about not
settling for the local minima.
I'm going to use that.
But I actually had
a question for you
about breadth versus
depth when you
come to deciding what
you want to work in.
Do you have your own perspective
or from people you know,
when you should stick
to the same career
path for a long time versus
when you should decide to switch
and move ahead to
something else?
Because the year of
companies having lifers
is probably kind of now being
turned around by the start-ups,
so I was wondering what
you had to say on that.
CORINNA CORTES: I started
in the Bell Labs system.
I was there for 15
years, and I thought
I would be there forever.
I was commuting for
15 years from New York
City to New Jersey.
Then all of a sudden, well,
the telephone industry
had been going down, right?
And the internet was going up,
and Google was in New York.
And it was clear that Google
was a good search engine,
and it hadn't gone public yet.
But if it was not going
to be Google itself,
then it was just going to
be bought by somebody else.
So I made the move.
I think you often
know with yourself.
But allow yourself
to think it through.
Is it time?
If you begin to think it's
time, it's probably time.
Right?
And then there's often
the danger, then,
you just stick around
for another five years,
because that's the easy thing.
Right?
And you don't have
to upset anything,
and you don't actually
have to do anything.
But if you begin to even
think the thought, it's time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, it
was a great talk.
And being a mom
of a two-year-old
and a graduate student,
I can relate to it a lot,
and it was great inspiration.
So call me a nerd.
I have couple of technical
questions with respect
to image clustering.
First of all, when you get
new data, like new images,
how do you train
them for the samples?
Like what would be
the time period?
So because everything is based
on the data from the web,
right?
CORINNA CORTES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
make sure to incorporate
the new data as
well into algorithm?
CORINNA CORTES: So the
clustering we're doing,
we don't redo it very often.
Also because we have
billions of images,
and even if you add
100,000 new images a day,
it doesn't change too much.
But of course there
could be completely
new things that are popping
up, and you begin to
just having that they all
end up down in the same node,
and you have to recluster.
I don't think that we change
the clustering too often.
But we should probably-- and we
probably do-- once in a while.
Right?
Every half year.
Just scratch at all,
and start all over.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the second question
is about deep learning.
Can we use deep learning kind of
thing like for image clustering
and the neural
networks behind it?
CORINNA CORTES: Don't get
me started in deep learning.
OK.
So I have the right to
be hard on deep learning.
I was at the labs where
[INAUDIBLE] also was.
We were in the same group
for many, many years.
So he's a good friend
of me, and deep learning
is not the answer to everything.
Deep learning is just another
machine learning algorithm.
So I have I worked on support
vector machines a lot.
I hold the patent for support
vector machines actually.
So that's another-- so
there's deep learning.
That's a non-convex
optimization problem.
You have no clue
what you're doing.
You're getting into
a local minimum.
It might be a perfectly
good local minimum,
but you have no
generalization guarantees
for the deep networks.
Convex optimization is
often a different story.
You know what you're
doing is one minimum.
You can find your way into it,
and a lot of those algorithms
also come with
learning guarantees.
That doesn't mean that
deep learning hasn't
had impressive results recently.
We've had two instances
where it has outperformed
many of the other algorithms
that we otherwise see.
They're characterized by being
multi-class classification
problems.
And we're not talking
multi-class like it's ten
classes that we
have to recognize.
It is hundreds of
millions of classes.
It has exactly been
in the image world.
Right?
There are some standard data
set out there and images.
Of course, there's so
many objects in the world.
Right?
So if you need a classifier
for your job objective,
we're talking multi- multi-
multi-class recognizers.
They are in an acoustic
model where we also
have hundreds of
thousands of classes.
These are the two instances
when neural networks recently
have outperformed anything else.
So yes, neural networks can
be used for image recognition.
It's not the only solution.
I'm waiting for the
other learning algorithms
to somehow dig in to
or find out what is it
about the neural
networks that make
them work so well
in these regimes?
And how can we leverage that
incorporated in our learning
algorithms, and be even better?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Awesome.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: We'll
just take one more.
CORINNA CORTES: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for sharing
your experiences.
I'm also a runner, so I
wanted to know, I guess,
what made you pick
running as a hobby,
and what parallels do you see
between your hobby, running,
and your career as a
researcher at Google?
CORINNA CORTES:
Running is so easy.
Right?
All you need is a
pair of running shoes.
And they last a long time.
There's no equipment you
otherwise need to buy.
So that's one of the reasons
that I picked running.
It's something you can
just go out and do.
The other reason-- no,
I didn't pick running.
It was actually, there were
some of these guys also,
the vacuum cleaner guys.
They were also running.
So they actually not only
got me to change career,
but they also got
me into running.
But the reason I
stuck with running
is probably because
it's so easy to do.
I can do it at all
hours of the day.
I can get up at 3 o'clock at
night, and I can go running.
And I think it's great
for solving problems,
because I'm out there
just with myself.
I have to live with just myself.
And I can take all the problems
that I have in my head,
and I can turn them around.
I can look at them.
It's just the
miles and the miles
and the miles and the miles.
People that cannot interact,
the problems that I solve.
I debugged a lot of
code out running.
The space, the endlessness of
it, the calmness, the peace.
I solve a lot of my
problems out there.
I think it's good
for me as a manager.
One thing I have noticed also.
I run away from my family.
I have to be honest.
If they're not around, I
don't go running as much.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]